[Music]
my aunt took opinion bang-bang don't you
have a lovely voice you know whoa how
long have you been standing there
not long two or three hours I like
watching you hack I've been up all night
getting everything you need for the
North Korea job what's the holdup the
cash the hot air balloon oh just steal
one from a New England cider festival
like we always did
there's got to be an easier way to get
this done sure you and your team could
try programming a code to battle the
stacks net virus release it into the
cyber flow stream to bring down
Pyongyang's computer network but we both
know that's a band-aid solution my
strategy deals with the human cause and
I get to ride in a hot-air balloon I'll
call you and everything's ready sounds
good so maybe you should go get a good
night's sleep hmm I'm not gonna sing
anymore
bye-bye then
[Music]
Topol we got everything the balloon is
at Andrews Air Force Base the briefcases
are waiting on the docks at dandong
you're good to go good to go alright I
am I what's good - mm-hmm
what's wrong I winters I'm scared it's
been years since I was in the field what
if I don't have it in me anymore don't
be scared
you got this your special agent Henry
topple unstoppable spy machine you're
not some washed-up dinosaur go put on
that fake mustache and get ready to go
kick some real ass I'll look for my
spirit gum but if it's gone bad Lord
calling it off special projects Nicole I
can still fit into my moustache I'm
about to go buckwild on these
is officially on
that's what I like to hear
now go solve this North Korea crisis so
we can get back to eavesdropping on
regular people this is gonna be one sick
balloon ride winters better hang up
before you get whiplash bang ticka ticka
ticka ticka meow meow ticka ticka ticka
bang a dong ba ba Wang ping skip Ooba
dooba dooba dooba seafood it'd be deeper
up we do banks we've anybody Gong mmm
Yama meow